el 29 de mayo de 1832
evarist calva sabía que era la última
noche de su vida
aquel muchacho revolucionario vehemente
y algo alocado
sabía que al día siguiente moriría a los
20 años de edad
había quedado citado con un capitán de
la guardia en duelo y sabía que no tenía
ninguna oportunidad
así que el mariscal bajo pasó la última
noche de su vida escribiendo
escribió cartas a sus familiares a tus
amigos y escribió todas las matemáticas
que huían
en aquel cerebro adolescente condenado a
apagarse al día siguiente demasiado
temprano
su última carta a su amigo y se va le
muestra mi trabajo a yacob y hauché
jacoby uno de los más grandes gauss
probablemente el más grande
al día siguiente el arma del capitán de
la guardia fuera bala o espada atravesó
el vientre de mariscal
yo hoy tengo algo más del doble de 20
años de edad y cuando yo tenía 20 años
de edad en todo aquel mar de asignaturas
de la carrera de matemáticas álgebra
análisis estadística topología había una
solo una que tenía el nombre propio
teoría de galúa
qué fue lo que inventó aquel muchacho
asustado la última noche de su vida para
que todos los aprendices de matemáticos
de todo el mundo lo estudiemos a los 20
años de edad
seguramente ahora que ríes que es lo
contara verdad seguramente ahora queréis
saber qué es lo que dice galván la lo
resolvió un problema de siglos y le dio
una solución perfecta bellísima
brillante y abrió caminos nuevos a las
matemáticas las matemáticas que inventó
galúa son las que describen el
comportamiento de las partículas
elementales del universo hoy en día y a
la vez describen la simetría de los
suelos de las paredes del palacio nazarí
de la alhambra de granada
si os gustaría que os contara la
historia verdad y si yo os la contara
empezaríamos en las matemáticas recién
nacidas de los babilonios de los griegos
y caminaremos por la historia
acompañando en momentos muy difíciles a
los matemáticos a los grandes
matemáticos de todos los tiempos que
fracasaron muchas veces donde triunfó
galúa acompañaríamos a ese muchacho
asustado en la última noche de su vida
y también acompañaríamos a los
matemáticos de los 200 últimos años que
han ido recorriendo los caminos que
abrió galúa y vosotros querríais venir
conmigo
y ese es el poder de las historias que
nos hacen atrevernos a entrar al
castillo encantado junto con juan sin
miedo a pasar la noche y nos hacen [ __ ]
de la mano a basilisa y entrar en la
cabaña de la terrible bruja baba yagá y
nos hacen también acompañar a simbad en
el desierto en el mar para ver qué
tesoro se encuentra en sus siete viajes
las historias nos hacen querer ver el
final nos hacen acompañar al
protagonista
aunque la cosa se ponga difícil y
aburrida y no me vais a creer pero a
veces en matemáticas las cosas se ponen
difíciles y aburridas
las matemáticas las ciencias están
llenas de historias son la historia de
nuestro descubrimiento del mundo yo
podía contar la historia de que lord
cantor el hombre que miró al infinito a
los ojos y acabó enloqueciendo o la
historia de ramanujan una adolescente
desconocido al que la diosa nama guiri
le dictaba en sueños los secretos de los
números o la historia de los 300 años
que pasaron los matemáticos tratando de
resolver un problema que apenas que
había en el margen de un libro me
encantaría contar las historias pasaría
horas aquí
y vosotros seguirías conmigo porque las
historias hacen que aquello que parece a
veces aburrido y difícil que no tiene
nada que ver conmigo sí tenga que ver
conmigo por qué
porque está dentro de nuestro ser cuando
te cuentan historias te miran a los ojos
te tienen en cuenta
y tú te conviertes en protagonista de la
historia y en autor
somos seres orales y abrir espacio a las
historias contadas a la palabra dicha en
nuestras vidas en nuestras casas en
nuestras aulas nos hace más ser quiénes
somos los humanos llevamos milenios
contándonos historias todos los grupos
étnicos en todas las épocas en todos los
lugares del mundo han tenido sus
narradores sus cuenteros los chamanes
los bululú es a veces serán los
sacerdotes los que contaban las
historias del pueblo a veces en a las
madres las matronas las abuelas no se
contaban aquellas historias las que
ponían voz cuerpo y alma que que viene a
ser lo mismo a las historias del pueblo
el tema de la historia el contenido de
las historias siempre el mismo quienes
somos
cómo es el mundo en el que estamos la
misión de las historias siempre la misma
caminar juntos con los que se fueron los
que están o los que vendrán construir la
comunidad la comunidad no se construye
sólo con las leyes y las costumbres la
comunidad la construyen también las
historias las míticas las legendarias es
verdad puede que hayamos pasado de ese
paradigma mítico de ese paradigma
legendario y estemos en un paradigma
científico de comprensión pero el poder
de las historias no ha pasado
durante milenios en todas las latitudes
en todos los grupos étnicos en todos los
momentos
los narradores los cuenteros han
desarrollado técnicas muy eficaces para
transmitir las historias de la tribu las
contaban de forma que no se olvidarán y
no se olvidan las contarán de forma que
fueran significativas para cada miembro
de la tribu y cada niño cada adulto cada
anciano sentía esas historias como
propia eran la parte más esencial del
ser del pueblo eso no se podía perder
a lo largo de la historia en todas las
formas de ser humanos ha habido sobre la
tierra contar historias ha sido una
parte esencial de nuestro ser hoy día
a la respuesta de que es el mundo que
somos nosotros la llamamos ciencia y
cultura y a su transmisión la llamamos
educación
y los que asumimos ese reto de
implicarnos en esa transmisión
demasiadas veces olvidamos a los
cuenteros a los narradores a los griots
a los gurúes que nos precedieron en este
oficio sagrado
el día siguiente de que el 30 de mayo de
1832 en que el arma del capitán de la
guardia fuera bala españa atravesó el
vientre de mariscal va
su hermano sostenía llorando el cuerpo
agonizante de aquel muchacho
vehemente revolucionario algo alocado
dígalo a marista
lo miro a los ojos y le dijo sus últimas
palabras no llores
no llores y dame valor porque necesito
todo el valor del mundo para morir a los
20 años de edad
[Aplausos]
[Música]